Sam, I would like to ask you question
related to the Holy Trinity versus
unholy Trinity.
I'm drinking as well. I don't know what
you're drinking.
>> But I have heard from the
I'm not trying to make fun of you. Slow.
Okay.
>> is very thick. I'm trying to follow,
honestly. So, now I see that you're
Trinitarian. Okay. Slow. Go slow with me
cuz it's very thick. So, I'm thinking
you're probably
Holy Trinity versus unholy Trinity.
Okay. Yes. That's correct. Because I
have heard from the exorcist, Father
Daniel Rehill. Catholic this, brother.
All right, man. You're Catholic. Here
you go, man.
You want to show You want me to
put up your screen, Sam?
Uh what Well, he didn't ask me a
question of scripture yet. Okay.
So, maybe it was Father Daniel Rehill. I
can't really remember. Or it was Father
Chad Ripperger.
They were talking about the
uh unholy Trinity. It was exactly when
they encountered Satan during the
exorcism.
So, I have made some connections on my
own. So,
how I see it
is that the Satan
is the first inversion
uh of the personality of God, God the
Father.
Because Satan is father of lies. Slow
it.
Brother, people don't think you're
blaspheming. Let me explain what he's
saying.
Ooh, this accent. Let me explain what
he's saying. He's saying there's an
unholy Trinity, people.
So, just like you have in the Godhead,
the Father,
in the unholy Trinity, you have Satan.
So, he's not saying Satan is a
personality of the Father. So, that's
how it sounded like. That's what you
sounded like. So, you got to be careful.
Speak slow, brother. Your accent.
Someone's [snorts] going to think you're
saying, "Yeah, Satan is a personality of
the Father." That's blasphemy. No, he's
saying
you have holy Trinity, unholy Trinity.
Holy Trinity, the Father is first. Well,
in unholy Trinity, Satan is first. Okay.
Now, what Who's the second?
>> Yes. That's That's correct. That's how
How I see it. The second one is Lucifer.
He is the second inversion of
personality. And he's ver- He's
inversion of Christ.
Who's Lucifer?
>> Because
Lucifer
uh
He is, like I said, inva- uh
inversion of Christ. He's like He's the
liar. person is the His name is Lucifer.
Right.
Right?
That's correct. Yes. Who's right?
>> unholy Trinity. Where did you get that
the second
member of the unholy Trinity is named as
Lucifer?
So, I I listened to the story he's he's
listening He's talking about from Father
Yeah, so
Father Ripperger was in an exorcism and
he explains all the conferences, all the
podcasts he talks about this exorcism.
He says that Satan's the inversion of
the person of God the Father and Lucifer
um in his name uh referring to the light
is the inversion Yeah, light bears the
inversion of Jesus Christ who shows us
the light. And then he he was in an
exorcism one time and he said the
possessor of the person was Beelzebub
and Beelzebub said, "I'm the mockery of
the Holy Spirit." Just really loud. And
then sunk
to where Father Ripperger couldn't bring
Beelzebub back up. And Father Ripperger
began interceding, asking the Blessed
Lady for intercession to to cuz he was
dumbfounded. He's like, "What does that
mean?" And then And you know, he left.
He wouldn't answer any more of his
questions. And it dawned on him it was
revealed to him in this exorcism that
Satan or the devil has dissociative like
personality disorder.
And he he asked He asked Beelzebub
or he actually he refers to Beelzebub as
the third personality of Satan. He said
when he did that, the the possessed gave
him this look like, "How'd you figure
that out?" And then he asked him later
Yeah, yeah, so I don't I don't know what
question he's leading up to from it. But
I remember Let me correct this guy real
quick. Brother, that's not an inversion
of the Holy Trinity cuz that's one
particular person who's manifesting
multiple personalities. That's not the
Trinity. That would actually be what
this guy used to believe, modalism.
So,
when you're telling me the one person is
Satan,
but another personality is Lucifer,
another personality he's Beelzebub,
that's still the one same person.
And he's got multiple personality
disorder.
That's not the Trinity. That's modalism.
All right. All right. I'm good.
That's where you confuse me.
So, you So, so everyone understand,
Lucifer
is the same person as Satan, the same
person as Beelzebub, but it's different
personalities cuz Satan uh has multiple
personalities.
But God is not multiple personalities.
Right.
>> God is
Father, Son, Holy Spirit. They're not
the same person. They're one person who
then can switch into another
personality. That's a disease. That's an
illness. That's a defect. Now, someone
said, "Well, it's a defect in us. That
doesn't mean it's a defect in God." But
no, no.
The Bible's quite clear. The Father
doesn't then change personality to the
Son. No, no. I'm not claiming that.
That's not the same. Not claiming that
at all because I don't believe it. Sam,
I'm going to I'm going to run to the
restroom, brother. So, if you do need to
bring up some passages, I'm going to
leave it at that.
>> Yeah, that's fine. What was it now,
brother?
No, I'm not claiming that that the God
is changing personalities because I know
it's three in one. So, I believe that
with my whole heart. Yes, though. Satan
is changing his personalities from Yeah,
I got that now. Satan, Lucifer, and
Beelzebub. That's not a the best
analogy.
The best analogy
>> the thing in the story, Sam, is
Father Ripperger asked Beelzebub later
in the exorcism, "Is your like Is your
trifurcated personality like the fact
that you suffer this tripersonal like
personal personality disorder? Is that
your punishment for trying to be like
God?" And Father Ripperger says that
Beelzebub basically told him, "Yeah,
that was his punishment." Cuz he Father
Ripperger was talking about how people
with
multiple personality disorder, they
they're like chronically in emotional
pain. And he was talking about how Satan
is chronically in emotional pain. But he
basically just asked the demon,
Beelzebub, "Is that your punishment for
trying to be God or trying to be like
God?" And he basically said, "Yeah." So.
Yeah, I don't think Father Ripperger
believes that about the Trinity, either.
No, I know he doesn't believe He can't
believe that because then we'd have to
throw him out of the church and
and get an exorcist to exorcise him. All
right, but my friend,
you see my playlist right there?
Yes.
I'll tell you what the counterpart to
the Trinity is from scripture cuz what
Father Ripperger experienced, that's
something personal and private and
subjective. Meaning, that doesn't mean
it's wrong. That means it doesn't rise a
level dogma that we have to now swear by
and follow it. You with me there?
Yes. Can be true because he's not lying.
But the demon may be lying. I don't
know. But it's not something dogma where
I have to swear by him. That's something
private, personal, subjective.
But I will show you from scripture where
Satan tries to mimic the un- the the
glorious, perfect, beautiful Trinity.
It's in Revelation 13, my brother. If
you go here, I just did a session last
week. I've done one a while back.
If you open up Revelation 13, we're
going to just go through it real
quickly. If you guys are okay with it,
it's up to you.
>> Perfect. Thank you. All right.
This is the example.
In Revelation 13, you have the dragon,
Satan,
the devil,
the serpent. But then you have a beast
coming up. He's a human ruler. Notice
he's flesh.
Having 10 horns and seven heads.
And on his horns were 10 diadems. And on
his heads were blasphemous names. Now,
what's interesting about this beast,
not only does the dragon give him all
his power and authority.
So, now notice Satan the dragon is the
head.
The beast comes. He's a ruler. He's
human.
And he's given all the power and
authority and the throne of the dragon,
right?
Yeah. But they're not the same person
and it's not multiple personality
disorder, correct?
Correct. What's amazing about the beast,
if you read, he suffers a mortal wound.
He's killed by a sword, but then he
comes back to life. Sound Sound
familiar?
Mhm.
You sure it sounds familiar? You're
saying, "Mhm."
Yes, because that's in the Bible that he
was deadly wounded, but he was brought
to life again.
He is killed by a sword and he comes
back to life. Does that sound familiar?
All right. You were speaking about that
before.
Who? About about the Christ.
You got it. When he was in human form on
earth. relation to Christ. I'm going to
show it to you right there. So, just
Hopefully, guys, my coffee's spilling
like crazy
because when you mentioned exorcism,
the cat that's possessed must have came
and done something to my coffee.
Do we have exorcists that will do
exorcism on cats?
Does anyone know?
We have Geo. He'll eat your cat. All
right. Okay, even better. Or maybe we
can get Johnny Pastor or something.
Okay. Now, let me let me go there. Okay,
sorry, guys. My coffee's spilled all
over.
That's why it sucks being single, dude.
At least, you know,
you have a wife, you can then treat her
like a Muslim man with a wife. Sit in
the kitchen, woman. Pop out babies. I'm
just kidding. That's Islam. I'm not a
Muslim. All right. Now.
So, now the second beast,
he is killed by a sword and he comes to
life.
But then you have a third beast here. It
says right here, "And I saw one of his
heads as if it had been slain fatally."
Notice,
"slain fatally and his fatal wound was
healed." "The whole earth marveled and
followed after the beast. And they
worshiped the dragon cuz he gave
authority to the beast. And they
worshiped the beast." Hmm.
Two distinct entities being worshiped.
"Who is like the beast who is able to
wage war with him?" Notice how it's
mocking God because we say, "Who is like
God?"
Who is like God? Anyway.
now there's a third entity,
a third entity that rises.
Who we call the false prophet, but also
the beast.
He's another beast.
And he had two horns like a lamb,
and he was speaking as a dragon.
He exercised all authority of the first
beast in his presence. Now,
this one mimics the Holy Spirit. Why?
If you read your Bible, the spirit is
the one who convicts the world of sin,
righteousness, and judgment. Convicts
the world of sin because they don't
believe in Jesus.
Convicts the world of righteousness,
vindicating Jesus, convincing the world
Jesus did not die the death of an
accursed false Messiah cuz God raised
him, he's alive. So, the spirit
convinces you of that. And of judgment,
convicting and convincing the world that
Jesus died to destroy Satan.
But how does the spirit do that? Through
miracles, right?
You with me there? Yes, I'm with you.
I'm listening to you.
Not only that,
when God created man,
they were created to be images of God,
right?
Right, yes.
And then God breathed
the breath of life into the nostrils of
man and made him a living soul. So, God
took dust,
fashioned it,
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life, the Holy Spirit. The spirit
animated man, and man became a living
image bearer of God, right?
Right, it was through the Ruach Elohim.
What is it? Ruach. Yeah, Ruach Elohim.
Now, watch what this beast does. You
ready?
And he exercises all authority of the
first beast in his presence, and he
makes the earth and those who dwell in
it to worship the first beast whose
fatal wound was healed.
He does great signs. Look, he does signs
and wonders to convince you to worship
this beast.
So, that he even makes fire come down
out of heaven to the earth in the
presence of men.
And he deceives those who dwell on the
earth because of the signs which were
given to him to do in the presence of
the beast,
telling those who dwell on the earth to
make an image. Now, notice the mockery
of the true God. God made an image,
mankind,
who had the [clears throat] wound of the
sword
has come to life. Notice, the beast was
killed and came to life.
Does that sound like Jesus?
Kind of, yes. Yes, because Christ was
killed.
But he came to life. This beast was
killed, but he came to life. How? I
don't know.
So, now what will that other beast do?
Take the image of this beast,
animate it, make it alive,
so that people will now worship the
beast and his image.
And it was given to him to give breath
to the image of the beast,
so that the image of the beast would
even speak and cause as many as do not
worship the image of these to kill. Here
is the mockery of the Trinity. Notice,
three and only three.
One Satan, the head of the beast, so we
can say that he's trying to play the
role of the Father.
That beast playing the role of Christ,
he's in the flesh, he demands to be
worshipped, he's killed, but physically
comes to life. And this other beast who
does signs and wonders to convince
people to worship the first beast, and
one sign he does, he gives breath to the
image and makes it alive.
That's exactly what God did.
This is where you can use Satan
to prove that even Satan knows God is a
Trinity.
Because why is he mocking
uh Father, Son, and Spirit
in that it's only three, and these three
alone, Satan the dragon, the beast, and
the false prophet, if God himself is not
a Trinity,
even down to the
fact that the second beast mocks and
mimics Jesus being killed physically and
coming to life, and the other one
mocks the spirit in doing miracles,
signs, and wonders to convince you to
follow that beast with such as giving
breath to the image of the beast. That's
how you know that even Satan knows God
is a Trinity.
Yeah, and I strongly assume that
if Satan would know what what will be
what will happen after Jesus choosing
sacrificing himself on the cross for us,
for our sins, he would never go with his
plan.
Now, let me finish this with some more
points to show you the connection. So,
notice he gives
breath to the image of the beast, right?
So, that the image of the beast would
even speak and cause as many as do not
worship the image of the beast to be
killed. He causes all, the small and the
great, the rich and the poor, and the
free men and slaves. Galatians 3:28,
Revelation 5:9-10. That's what Jesus
did. He came to redeem all these classes
of people. But what will he put on them?
That they will be given a mark on their
right hand or on their forehead.
And that no one will be able to buy or
to sell except the one who has the mark,
either the name of the beast or the
number of his name. So, notice, you have
to have the mark signifying the name of
the beast and the number of the beast,
and you must worship the image of the
beast that came to life and the beast,
right? Right, yeah. I want to tie it in
with the beautiful, glorious Trinity.
And if you still doubt
that this is making fun and mocking the
Trinity,
>> No, no doubting.
Notice, 666, three multiples of six, not
two or four.
Why three? Cuz there are three. But why
are they three? Mocking the true three,
the triune God. But now catch it.
He's going to force the mark,
which is the number and the name of the
beast, to be on their forehead, right
hand, right?
And he gave breath to the image,
correct?
All right, my brother from different
mother mother.
>> Yes,
I agree with you. Okay, now don't agree
with me. I want to show you something.
Can you reply me, man? Here.
Look how he's mocking the Trinity.
Revelation 3:12.
He overcomes, I'll make him a pillar in
the sanctuary of my God,
and he'll never go out from it anymore,
and I will write on him the name of my
God. There it is, the name.
The beast will demand you take the name
of the beast, the number of his name,
and the name of the city of my God, the
New Jerusalem, which comes down out of
heaven from my God and my new name. Yes,
New Zion.
What is it?
The New Zion.
New Zion. New Zion, sir. New Zion. Oh,
yeah, you confused me. Yeah, because it
will replace New Jerusalem, we know
that. It's not new, it's old. It's the
actually the ancient one.
>> Yeah, which is in heaven.
Astaghfirullah, man. Then here,
>> [clears throat]
>> Revelation 14:1. Then I looked, behold,
the lamb was standing on Mount Zion, and
with him 144,000 having his name and the
name of his father in now their
foreheads. The name of the beast was
written where?
Right hand or the forehead. You see who
is mocking? Mhm.
Revelation 13 shows you Satan's making
fun, mocking, mimicking the Trinity,
even down to the name.
Just like the beast will demand you take
the mark of the beast, the mark of his
name as number, on your forehead, right
hand, the true God will mark you
with the name of God the Father and the
lamb on your forehead. You see the mock
mimicry? That's what I was trying to
show here.